These are the most diverse Russell Group universities.
Now this is measured by
the percentage of attendance by ethnic minorities.
At No. 10 we have university of Cambridge at 29.1%.
At No. 9 we have university of Nottingham at 30.4%.
At No. 8 we have university of Manchester at 33.3%.
At No. 7 we have university of Birmingham at 34.1%
at No. 6 at university of Warwick at 43.1%,
at No. 5 at University College London at 58.2%,
at No. 4 at Imperial College London at 61.6%.
At number three
we have London
School of economics and Political Science at 62.6%.
At number two
we have King's College London at 66.4%.
And the most diverse Russell Group
university would be Queen Mary
University of London at 81.3%.